forty-five million Americans have lost
their jobs in the last five months or so
an odds are one in three of you in
America watching this probably needs
this video because you just got fired
and you don't know what to do next and
by the way if you know anybody that got
fired and it's not you this video could
be for them as well because this is what
we're going to cover in today's video
number one twelve reasons why people got
fired how to increase your income to
have your biggest income your everyn
2021 questions to ask yourself realities
of income that nobody wants to talk
about because it's too painful have you
improved yourself during the pandemic
and how to identify your next five moves
to come out of the pandemic stronger so
the reason why we're doing this series
called your next five moves is because I
have a book coming out August 18 with
Simon & Schuster which gives you the
formula on how to identify your next
five moves on whatever situation you may
be as a CEO as a founder as an investor
as an executive as somebody coming up
you just got fired you lost your
business you file bankruptcy marriage
whatever maybe you need to know your
next five moves stick around by the end
I'm gonna give you a method of getting a
free chapter to the book before the book
comes up so having said let's get right
into it twelve reasons why people got
laid off or fired in the last five
months your number one is coronavirus
lay off companies let people go we have
to let go of 10% of our employees 20% of
our employees and maybe you were one of
them number two you got fired for your
effort you didn't show effort whether
people went home and they were working
from home or maybe your effort wasn't
the best they fired you for that that
happens all the time
the next one is your project was
completed you came in you had a task you
got a project it took three months six
months 12 months 18 months let's pin
down you're fired we don't need to thank
you so much all the best you number four
a technology replaced you meaning
whatever job you were doing was replaced
by a technology or a system that can do
your job number five money fired you the
company was getting tighter and money
and they had to figure out a way to you
know cut costs and one of the ways was
they have to fire you number six was
your hours were cut meaning you were
used to working 40 hours a week now it's
20 you're not full-time the benefits not
the same that is a method of being fired
you lost 20 hours of your income which
is 50% your income that is a
being fired number seven your attitude
got you fired your attitude just was
rubbing people the wrong way maybe
negative may be complaining whatever and
maybe that could have been the case that
you got fired number eight your size of
thinking got you fired what do I mean by
size of thinking we had somebody the
other day that I offered a full-time job
to and it was a nice salary he says ah
you know what I gotta tell you I know
this is kind of gonna sound a little
weird but where I'm making $4,000 a
month staying home and I'm doing side
jobs I don't want a job right now
because I'm able to stay home and not do
anything and this thing is kind of
helping me out so the person didn't take
a job with a company because he was
getting money it's size of thinking
problem thinking so small that an
unemployment check got them fired and
they're happy staying where they're at
number nine a big client fire you you
you were handling the client you didn't
handle it well didn't go right maybe you
could have done a better job the client
said I just can't work with you anymore
you're fired that is a method of being
fired number ten company outgrew you and
number 11 you have couldn't handle the
pressure during times like this there's
a lot of pressure taking place and
number 12 the culture fired you you
don't fit the culture now here's the
thing if you heard me go through this
some of you guys are like screw this guy
the hell with you pat who are you to
tell me it's all the company's fault
it's what the company did my boss sucks
you were not there to see what they were
doing all these greedy people fine if
that's the attitude I cannot help you
with your income the only thing I know
what to do as a person that's been fired
before by Bob's Big Boy
because I was working there and quite
frankly I was not the best employee and
they fired me the only thing I can do is
what do I need to do to increase my
income I can't change Bob's Big Boy you
can't change your company you can't
change your boss you can only change you
this is why we're starting here now
let's look at the income income wise one
of the exercises I want you to do is the
following number one I want you to write
down on a piece of paper what was your
income in 2015 what did you make in 2016
2017 2018 and 2019 now I put it this way
and I left 2020 white because we don't
necessarily know how two years gonna end
up with the income that you're making
and you can't you can't count your
income from unemployment that's not
income
talking about I'm talking about you
generating income right so when you
write down your income 20 15 16 17 18 19
here's what you'll notice this person
here was making seventy two thousand
dollars in 2015
went up to eighty eight a sixteen
thousand dollar race next you came down
to 79 next you to 115 makes you to
seventy seven so if you look at this one
fifteen looks pretty but the reality is
the last three years there no matter
what income is what $77,000 your income
right they would like to make more money
but seventy-seven the market says that's
your income now you have three questions
to us number one what do you think
you're worth okay I'm not talking about
like the song I'm one in a million I'm
not talking about kind of stuff what do
you think you're worth today in a
marketplace you're running a company
somebody like your qualifications comes
in for an interview you have your budget
that you have to it what are you willing
to pay that person which is you what
would you pay that person to marketplace
now you may say Pat I think I'm worth
$100,000 okay next thing you have to
answer is why why do you think you're
worth that what makes you say that
I am worth the numbers that you just
said answer that here's why I think
great no problem here's the next thing
what's the difference between what you
believe you make and what the market but
the market is paying you're meaning you
believe you're worth 150 the markets
only paying you 77 there's a seventy
three thousand dollar discrepancy why is
there such a discrepancy there if you
really are worth 150 shouldn't the
market pay you for it well yeah but I
think I'm worth 150 it's good to have
positive thinking but then you have to
use logic to know why wouldn't the
market pay me what I'm worth there's a
reason for so now let's look at some
realities of income that's out there you
have to learn this and it's kind of
painful and it sucks but I'd rather know
it upfront then find out about it twenty
years later and I'm 63 years old I want
to know about it now just like you
probably don't want to know about it now
number one your income the reality it's
not going to change dramatically the
next 30 to 90 days meaning 2020 your
dreams are probably not going to become
a reality if you just got fired from
your job it's not going to happen in
twenty and twenty and sometimes the
problem with people is that they want
everything to change one right away oh
man I want to caught them chase I want
to do something right now so my
semia message and they said padam sick
of it I hear you hear your story I watch
all your videos but I tell you I'm in a
terrible place right now with my family
with my mom I'm seeing all this stuff of
my dad like we're not in a good place is
what can I do right now for things to
change right now I need $35,000 to bail
out my parents I said you want the good
news or the bad news he said give me the
bad news first I said bad news is
there's probably nothing you can do
right now that can change things
immediately in the next 30 days I said
but there's a lot of things you can do
that can change things in the next 18
months but not in the 30 days because
nothing big happens immediately that the
results are being shown right so number
one for somebody say oh I was thinking
this is one of those where the secret
sauce is gonna be given to me and and
you know I thought I thought this is
gonna change everything if you're
wanting it within 30 days I don't have
any kind of solutions for you number one
because that's realities of income
number two if you say you make the most
fancy resume and you send it to the
companies big companies and you're
typically worth 77 and the company pays
you 180 you're like oh my gosh I got so
lucky I gotta chop for 180 this is sick
or the market value for you it's really
$42,000 your income somebody offers you
80,000 you think you on top of the world
I can't believe they finally paid me 80
here's what happens if you get lucky
with an over paying job that pays you
way above what you're really worth in a
marketplace and you don't deliver within
30 60 90 days you're going to be fired
okay companies learn very quickly
whether you're worth the money they paid
you or not within 30 60 90 days I've
experienced it very quickly you'll be
fired then you'll have to go back in the
marketplace and the markets gonna ask
you well my last job paid me 80 grand
really how about the job before that I
don't need to disclose it because in the
state of California state of tech not
only to disclose any of that stuff okay
no problem one last job pay eighty
thousand dollars how long were you at
the last job only twelve months why did
you leave cultural differences can we
call the references you give all the
references of people you like right you
never give the people that fired you
always give the people so no one company
hires you and then they fire you again
and then new company hires you
and they fire you again five years later
you work for six companies it's kind of
like being 33 years old married five
times in your life it's not the best
reputation to have to want to marry
somebody real serious so you may want to
step back and say what is my real market
value what why am I trying to get a fast
one with these companies here it's not
working out I keep getting fired let me
take a step back and what do I need to
do long term three money is out there
for people who know over how to
over-deliver what do I mean by this
everybody thinks the market sucks right
now people are not sitting on cash
there's a lot of cash out there in a lot
of different industries investors have a
lot of money the market is willing to
overpay for talent the markets will not
overpay for people that over deliver the
market today is very picky about paying
people who think they're worth more than
what they're worth today let me explain
I was on a call with a man named Andrew
Zimmern which you may know he had his
show called Bizarre Foods whatever
whatever Andrew Zimmern great show right
he was on TV from 2006 to 2018 and we're
having this conversation and he says a
story about a person that had this you
know year and a half ago this lady owns
a restaurant in San Francisco one of the
most well-known restaurants in San
Francisco when you see the interview
you'll hear him tell the story and she
decides to start really changing
compensation benefits all this other
stuff to keep her people and all this
other because she says I was having a
hard time keeping top talent why because
even if you pay in your top talent a
hundred thousand dollars a year and a
half ago people could take the hundred
thousand dollars with a resume to
another company get $120,000 because
people were hopping with their resumes
from company to company to company right
you could have done that a year and a
half ago not today okay because today
companies are frugal with their money
because remember money fired a lot of
people right okay so even if you think
well the money's up I can go get it yes
but the key word in this entire sentence
is what over-deliver number four your
skills maybe a low-paying skill time to
change your skill number five your
industry may be in a decline or your
industry just may not be at a time right
now that's going to be paying your high
income you need to know these realities
of income before making your next move
so now during the pandemic I see a lot
of face for poor
and I see a lot of people's comment
saying I just finished 42 episodes of
this shows the best I've ever watched 42
episodes
times 50 minutes that's 38 36 hours what
are you doing watching 42 episode I just
finished this other moment that was 120
episodes oh my gosh I'm emotionally
attached to Baron Armand - what are you
doing watching all this stuff you can
take in those 120 hours in a master
class online don't complain if people
don't want to hire you after pandemic
it's because your method after getting
fired maybe wasn't effective for you and
it's time to change so hear it here it
is how have you changed during the
pandemic based on skill set contacts
expertise attitude education work ethic
technology increase in market value DMA
what are your daily monitoring
activities what are things you're doing
on a daily basis that your discipline is
getting better and leadership wise what
have you done so again somebody may
watch this video and they may say Pat I
need to lift me up or man I don't need
something like this you're beating me up
a little bit I mean come on Pat I just
need somebody to tell me everything's
gonna be okay
I can tell you everything's gonna be
okay and lie to you because if you don't
change certain habits everything's not
gonna be okay it's actually gonna get
worse if you want nice motivational
videos there are millions of channels
out there that are going to tell you
videos that are awesome you are awesome
you are great you are amazing the way
you are today no you're not what you are
today is your market value if you want
this market value you're not gonna make
that money based on today's market value
so it's a very tough thing for me to
swallow 15 years ago to realize hey Pat
you ain't as good as you think you are
like what are you Tom I'm Patrick maybe
25 26 years old now you're really not as
good as you think you are you got to
change
I got a change you got a change the
moment it came from that perspective
lifestyle change so here's your last
five moves on what to do if I were you
number one why don't you get fired
meaning really why did you get fired by
the way I'm gonna talking about go to
your boss and say you know what I really
screwed up it was all my fault I'm not
telling you I'm telling you why did you
get fired what was the reason why you
got fired not why the company fire
because I'm assuming the company kept
some people so unless if you worked at a
company that let go of a hundred percent
of their employees well then that's a
different reason company went out of
business but if the company let go five
percent their employees ten percent
their employees twenty percent of
employees and it's the layoffs I just
want you know they let go of the least
needed least talented people that's what
companies do just just so you you broken
up with other people before in the past
right why did you break up because you
didn't see long-term benefits exchange
value like I just don't see this thing
working out its same way so now if you
were to be honest with yourself why did
you get fired what was the cause of it
how much of it was you what could you
have done differently that's number one
number two what's your immediate
solution what can you do today to
replace a portion or income immediately
get an immediate job what can you do
because you need to make your move and
get a job immediately because you can't
let a wound bleed because you got kids
you got family got jobs you need to stay
active what can you do immediately
that's number two number three which is
the most important one where do you want
to be a long term and here's what I mean
by what do you want to be long term when
I lost a client or when I was fired or
when a client fired me or when you know
I had a time where I was thinking too
small or when a time a you know
situation I had where I couldn't handle
the pressure and I lost a client or raw
somebody this is all things that I
couldn't do right I went back and I say
long-term Pat who do you want to be for
you the entire first law there's five
laws here that talks about you know your
next violence the entire move number one
is for your positioning meaning what do
you want to position yourself long term
most people don't spend a lot of time
thinking about this all they're thinking
about it's how can I pay my bills today
how do you want to position yourself
long term long term this is why I put an
income of 2021
most people want to fix their income
problems from 2020 I'm looking at 2021
2020 to 2025 when I was 26 years old 27
years old I was at Pebble Beach and I
started making some decent money and a
man asked me a question Pat at what age
will you have $100,000,000 we're at a
bar at Pebble Beach and he says at what
age will you have $100,000,000
I said I think by 40 out of 100
million-dollars right 100 million by 40
it happened 38 39 ish by the way 200
million dollars but what happened I used
to only think about immediate immediate
immediate so much why didn't think about
long-term steps of what I have to do the
sequencing of steps is what got me to
the vision that I wanted to get to
because I spent time thinking about
long-term rather than just quick quick
quick decisions to be making number four
what new skill sets do you need to
change in order to get paid what you
want to get paid in 2021 so skills
industry positioning what do you need to
do to be able to change that or whatever
that number may be for you whatever it
is study it now and the last but not
least so you may say I got fired man I
was in a health industry and I don't
like it I got fired I was in hotel
business I don't like it I got fired
because I wasn't realistic
I don't like it great what are the
industry do you want to go into go look
at that person number five whoever it is
that you're looking at as an industry
and study them hey John do you mind if I
reach out to you can I just come to your
office I just kind of want to see what a
day looks like yeah sure no I'm not
interested yeah sure come on down you go
to the office so what does it feel like
to be a financial advisor for 15 years
what does your day look like what's the
toughest thing was the easiest thing
what's the differentiator great you know
you go to real estate guy hey you've
been in a real estate business for 20
years do you mind if I come and just sit
down with you I just want to know what
it's like to be a real estate agent I'm
about to make a career decision for
myself I want to know what to do next
I'm thinking about leaving my industry
what is the real estate business look
like and you go on their luck okay cool
okay cool
here's your day here's the worst here's
the best what does it look like to be
this for what does it look like to start
a company what does it look like to do
this based on that you'll say this is
not the industry for me or this is the
industry for me but I definitely don't
want to be a CEO I prefer only being a
salesperson this is the industry for me
but I prefer to be a Sales Leader I
don't want to do this your positioning
is getting clearer and clearer and
clearer because you've identified your
next five moves again today when you
watch this video if you're somebody that
got fired and you have other people that
have got fired share this video with
them but if you're somebody that didn't
get fired and you're like you know
parody get fired you know people that
got fired share this with them people
need to have this conversation to make
the next decision so their dreams can
become a reality and again this is why I
wrote the book
your next five moves that's coming out
August 18th with Simon & Schuster I told
you earlier that I'm sharing a free
chapter to get a free chapter you can go
to your next five moves calm if you buy
one copy you preorder one copy we'll
send you a free chapter if you preorder
three copies we are sending over a
1-hour strategy session with four
different quadrants to be thinking about
on what you need to be doing next but
you'll need to buy three copies so you
buy one you get two free chapter you buy
three you get two one our strategy
session and a video I want you to watch
a video I want you to watch if you
haven't seen it yet is how to reach your
full potential if you've not watched it
click over here to watch the video and
again if you want to get the link to the
book text us at three one zero three
four zero 1 1 3 2 3 1 0 3 4 0 1 1 3 2
text next move one more time 3 1 0 3 4 0
1 1 3 2 text the word next move will
send you the link or if you're somewhere
around the world you're not on America
go to your next five moves calm spelled
out your next five moves calm to be able
to order copy for yourself thanks for
watching everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]